want to get the most out of your iPhone
here's how live photos Fiesta turn your
live photos into a dynamic video
Masterpiece combine them seamlessly and
relive those Unforgettable moments
battery saver reme head over to settings
then to accessibility then to display
and text size and reduce white Point
increase the percentage to save more
juice your battery will thank you
wallpaper Wizardry B of your wallpaper
duplication nor filter magic hit to
settings go to wallpaper switch to the
nor edit and lock your phone and watch
your screen transform series spell and
to all you Potter hits
Siri
lumos now you know